okay let's go to our next caller from
the seven seven three area code call her
from seven seven three go ahead hi I'm
calling from Chicago all right what's
your name uh it's awful David all right
go ahead David what's going on so the
question for you it it's it might be a
bit complicated even for a girl like you
packed in but I really would like to
know your input in this it's regarding
blockchain it's regarding blockchains
I'm sure you heard about crypto blocks
you know like the utility side of it not
more like as a currency but as a means
of usage for let's say making like
things at more at a better rate like
making things that are better rate you
mean like at a lower price or what or at
a higher speed more like if it's it's
like for instance have you heard of
eating like they're just above the
pledging right or read what would that
help us compete with like China and
because like you know like these
transporters they're always like oh we
can record again right right but they
don't do they even know the
possibilities that these igniters could
do for the economy okay pretty much
boost and in fact they're what which
what specifically are you asking me
about oh well short answer is do you
think they would actually help okay but
would what help I'm trying to understand
what you're saying blockchain in general
you said utility coins or but I just I
need the question you know answerest
Amazon right let's say they accept
beaching they are you saying v chain I
kept the only coin I know I just chose
reaching as an example but they can make
their own they could choose whatever
okay let's say they want to make
manufacturers extra lot of items sure
they could just put an algorithm through
the blockchain to make that happen with
have it like less waste with
more process which I say to America
would probably sounded really good
wouldn't you agree less waste and more
profit sounds appealing to for-profit
corporations for sure right but this
would seem like the whole point of
Satoshi's vision was to make it
decentralized to make the people have
power you know how Howard Democrats
Howard you know here in the US for
instance how would they potentially try
that they know who and from the people
about it in a way that's not last
complicated because even I don't get it
as much you know it's pretty comedy I
think that's the issue I think it's that
you don't get it as a result I don't
know what you're asking I think that
that that maybe tells us everything we
need to know about it I don't know I got
a run but it's not I think we've got to
clarify the question before we can
really dig into the answers but I do
appreciate the call